foreign
[Music]
where anime fans reject every
live-action adaptation usually for good
reason
Netflix finally cracked the code change
almost nothing no matter how ridiculous
it looks
good luck with season two
one piece
prepare for a live action shown in
series which is Japanese for targeted at
young boys and English 4 beloved by
grown men complete with the usual Shonen
tropes like hungry idiot hero one of
everything please overly serious rival I
want to be worthy of holding my own
against someone like Lucy and powers
that escalate until they literally punch
God in the face trust me they all get
there eventually
in this series that Taps into every
Fan's dream that one day they too might
go outside and make friends if they
hadn't spent a thousand hours watching
the Japanese equivalent of SpongeBob
worth it prepare for season one's
adaptation of romance Dawn the 100 or so
chapters of the manga that took place
before anything cool happens as you're
plunged into the salty world of one
piece a franchise where you're either a
pirate a marine or
oh
shoot I let him keep their hands
as our heroes spend all seasons
searching for a map to find the grand
line next up
Grand line do you know how to get that
there's a map to the Grand line the
grand one is just right
where is it exactly which is just this
world's version of the Equator this
spanned across the middle is the grand
line sailing East or West Dingus can't
miss it or are all of you the dumb one
which way is for the left but you said
five degrees starboard yeah it's the
other starboard Captain tastic ah so
does God meet Monkey D Luffy
after eating a literal forbidden fruit
he gained the power to throw glizzies of
infinite size now he's on a
single-minded quest to become king of
the Pirates I'm gonna be king of the
Pirates I will be the king of the
Pirates I'm gonna be king of the body
I'm gonna be king of the pipes boring
with only one thing standing in the way
of his dream he doesn't know what a
pirate does being a pirate is not about
Raiden Villages it hurts a scum they're
thieves and murderers not the Pirates I
know but we can't steal one what kind of
pirate are you
when you love being on boats not doing
crime that's called sailing you want to
be king of the sailors I can't let
innocent people get hurt because of me
see meet the rest of the Loof troop who
only join up after he beats them down
with toxic positivity we're a crew nope
together I'm sensing a little bit of
tension amongst the crew not a crew not
me you are our friend we are your crew
Nami is messed up because her parents
died and they one-pieced her guardian
right in front of her
Zorro is messed up because his parents
probably died and his best friend at
sword Camp lost a fight to the stairs us
up is messed up because he was abandoned
by his dad and watched his mom die and
now he'll lie his way into everything
but the easiest score in the East blue
Sanji is messed up because he got
abandoned by his parents and his mentor
had to eat his own leg so that he could
live to kick it up a notch you ate your
own legs bam
together they'll find their way to more
themed Pirates than this universe's
laser-guided wanted posters
like the cat Pirates
he uh let's just call him Street Sharks
and of course buddy the clown Prince of
piracy who may not get laughs from his
actual jokes but that won't stop him and
every other villain from yucking it up
at how deliciously evil they are
[Laughter]
hahaha
Luffy are you gonna laugh like a pirate
with us or what I'm a different kind of
pirate
worthless enjoy the beginning I would
sure to be a long journey with plenty of
mysteries left to uncover like how did
Luffy's British Father Figure in
Scottish Granddad raise a kid with that
accent you can give it back to me only
after you become a great pirate would
you expect to be a marine when you'll
wasting your time on this nonsense how
you find me anyway will Nami get the
same level of character development she
received in the anime who will be the
first to kiss these two or these two and
will all these lovable Misfits achieve
their dreams or will everyone fail to
defeat their chronic fatigue syndrome
I'd catch up on my sleep
need to knock it off I'm trying to take
a nap you woke me from my nap You're
Gonna Keep talking or let me get some
sleep
you can sleep when we get to the next
filler Arc
so set sail with a young cast of
unknowns who truly embody their
characters in this absolute ship show
with a pure childlike view of the world
it's more
complicated than that I don't really do
complicate it either full of
over-the-top silliness and Whimsy that
never gets in the way of the best part
everyone butchering each other like
feral Hogs
Shanks used to say not every situation
can be solved with violence oh that
sounds smart watch how is he from
starring Initial D aren't you glad I
didn't say bandana I was born on a
pirate ship with a bunch of apples Riff
Raff Street rat let him cook Larry
Potter Shanks For The Memories Dog the
Bounty Hunter you've been hit by you've
been struck by a smooth Emerald blog
life Hearts the clottish horror bake a
leg Prince Valium jaw Patrol that girl
is poisoned wait the butler actually did
it wake up sheeple cross dress for less
the time for waiting is over higher is
of age Chris Delia and the spins
come on
stop stop the ride I'm gonna
yo ho yo a pirate show for tweens
you'd never know that this was the same
company that made live-action Cowboy
Bebop I mean sheesh fans have gotten
toxic okay I guess they gave one clue
I'm gonna be king of the Pirates mama
had a chicken mama had a cow dad was
proud he didn't care how
stop asking me to say stuff in my epic
voice it's a medical condition I can't
control